[موسيقى]
يعطيكم العافيه وتحياتي لكم جميعا
بلشت افكر كتير شو بدي احكي بس اوقف
قدامكم هون
بس كنت عارفه انه في كتير مسجات بدي
اوصلها للعالم مريت بتجربه كان صعب كتير
بنت بعمر 12 سنه تمر فيها
بس انا هون مش عشان احكي قصه حياتي انا
لساتني يعني ما طبقت السنه القانوني
تقريبا سنه ونص بس راح احكي لكم من جوني
تبعتي الجوني
راح اشارككم التحديات اللي واجهتني
والدروس اللي تعلمتها اللي اكيد انا
استفدت منها وانا سبب وجودي هون هم هاي
الاشياء
بالبدايه قناتي بلشت بمدينه العين بدوله
الامارات
كنت عند بيت بنت صاحبه ابن صاحب بابا
يس كثير
بلشنا نعبي المعلومات
وصلنا
انا ما عندي ايميل عمري 12 سنه
لا احنا ما بنشارك بهيك جريمه
فروحنا على الاردن مرق الوقت وايفاوند
واللي هو ابن خالتي بس عملنا القناه من
كثر الحماس انا رحت ركضت وعملت فيديو كان
ويلكم
الفيديو خمس ثواني عليه
انا والعاشر برضو انا بس من الاكاونت ماما
هون انا بلشت اعمل فيديوهات اول فيديو
انتشر الي
فيديو تمثيل اربع كريك انا بعملهم
وكثير الناس حبوه فنجاح هذا الفيديو على
الرغم انه كان الفيديو كتير طرق بدائيه
يعني شو كنت بصور على ترابيزه كانت
الاستاندل الكاميرا والكاميرا اصلا ما
كانت كاميرا التليفون
كان يمر الفيديو بخمس تطبيقات عشان اوصل
للاندروزولت لانه ما عندي اللي عليه كل
اشي يشمل هذا الحكي
فالفيديو طلع
لا كتير قبول واعجاب من الناس عليها
انا هذا نجاح كتير كبير فنجاح هذا الفيديو
كان اكبر مشكله بالنسبه لي
كيف بدي احافظ على هذا المستوى كيف بدي
اكمل هل هاي بس ومضه وراح تروح ولا في
طريقه معينه فهنا لازم صار في تحدي هني
ابلش افكر بافكار جديده
النظام اللي انا كنت ماشيه عليه انه يكون
في عندي زي طرف خيط من موقف او من قصه
وبعدين يتحول لفكره عنوان فيديو
ذهبت الى السوبر ماركت واشتريت عشره اكياس
من الجيب
وبعدين تتحول لفيديو
بس بعدين كنت احيانا يعني انزل فيديوهات
يكون الفيديو
ببالي انه هذا راح يكسر الدنيا اسمه نار
اشتغل انزل احط فيه كتير كبير الفيديو ما
عم بلاقي نفس
اللي انا بدي اياه
فيديو ثاني الافرت فيه
ولا عملت عليه اشي بس انه خلص انا بدي
اكمل بنزله
ايوه هون انا فهمت اليوتيوب ما فيه منطق
هذا العالم مش معروف مش متوقع فانا كان
هذا الشيء لما ادركته يساعدني كتير اني
اتخلص من اللي انا فيه لما اشوف المشاهدات
عم بتقل او عم بتزيد
تحدي تاني واكبر من هيك واجهني اللي هو
اني اتعامل مع الكومنتس الكومنتس وخصوصا
الكومنتس السلبيه بمرحله انا كنت عم بكون
فيها شخصيتي فكنت واحد سلبي كان بيغطي على
عشره وعشرين اميت ايجابي هذا الصعوبه او
هون الصعوبه في الموضوع اني انا لازم
استوعب
كيف بدي اتعامل مع
فبلشت استوعب انه
انا لازم اكون واثقه وقادره افهم اني انا
عم بقدم اشي مفيد للناس حتى لو كانت
الفائده غير مباشره
ويكون عندي ثقه بالنفس حيث ثقل تخليني
انتقل من عمل لعمل من فيديو لفيديو بدون
ما تاثر بشكل رئيسي من الاخرين
ولغتي اللي بحاكي فيها نفسي تكون كتير
لطيفه وما اسعى حالي
لانه هذا الشيء هو اللي راح ياثر بعدين
بالمستقبل
على كيف راح اقدم وكيف راح اتطور
بعدين ننتقل هلا للابفورتشنتيز اللي تحت
لي اياها وجودي على السوشيال ميديا اكيد
صار عندي خبره بتعامل مع الناس وقدرت
اتعرف على الناس من مختلف الجنسيات
ماما برضو كورت صداقات مع كثير ناس لانه
هي دائما مرافقتي في كل مكان
[تصفيق]
اتعامل مع شركات انا كتير بحبهم وكان
يوصلني
هاي فرحه هيك بتوصلك هديه بس كنت اخبي جزء
من هاي
المنتجات وبابا لانه هو طبيب في المستشفى
فكنت اعطيه بس يطلع على المستشفى بس يخلص
من فحص المرضى هو طبيب اطفال فكان يعطيهم
شوي ويصورلي فيديو
يحسسني هيك بشعور سعيد انه انا قادره ارد
للمجتمع الدعم اللي عم بقدموا لي اياه
لليوم
وهذا جزء كتير مهم انا بدي اعمله عليه انه
انا كنت جزء من المجتمع ولازلت جزء من
المجتمع وهم كانوا سبب بالمكان اللي انا
وصلت له فكتير حلو انه اشوف حالي قادره
اساعدهم ولو بشيء بسيط بالمكان اللي وصلت
له وبنصح الجميع يعمل هذا الحكيم
شغله ثانيه انه مثلت انا مثلت مسلسل سلطه
بدور دينا
كان اشي يعني نرجع لبدايتي انا بلشت تمثيل
فانه تحليل فرصه اقدر اكمل بهذا الشيء
اتعلم اكثر عن الفيلم وتوز
كان اشي كتير كتير
وبس خلصت توجيهي اللي هي الثانويه العامه
احنا بنسميها بالاردن توجيهي هاي السنه
الرعب والتوتر كنت الي قاطعه السنه عن هذه
القناه سنه انا ما بنزل ولا فيديو
انستجرام كان بيعرف بس مش كنكتب مع المكان
اللي انا اصله
بلشت فيه
فكان يسبب لي هذا الحكي كتير مود سوينز
كنت اوصل لدرجه الاكتئاب
بس الحمد لله رغم كل هاد قدرت احصل معدل
كويس في التوجيهي يعني كويس عالي يعني
هذا المعدل
التحلي او كان الي القدره اني ادخل اي
تخصص بدي اياه بالاردن اي تخصص يعني كليه
الطب وفعلا دخلت اسبوع في كليه الطب ولكن
مش مرتاحه مش هذا المكان اللي بدي اياه
وحولت للتصميم تواصل البصري
فالسوشيال ميديا وجوديه فيها كان له كتير
دور كبير بهذا القرار قرار اني انا اختار
شو بدي باكمل بالمستقبل مش الرقم اللي انا
جبته اللي يختار
فكنت شايفه هذا الشيء كثير كويس كتير قوي
لي وساعدني كتير
[موسيقى]
انه قادر اكون انا متحكمه بنفسي ما اخلي
هاي الاشياء تتحكم فيها والصوره النبطيه
تضلها طاغيه على شو اللي انا بدي اياه وشو
انا ممكن ابدع بالمستقبل
فبالاخر بدي احكي لكم انه احنا عم نعيش
بعالم سريع عالم متغير لازم نواكبه
ونتكيف معه لكن بنفس الوقت لازم نحمي
حالنا منه اوكي السوشيال ميديا جود ممكن
تكون نافذتك انت تطلع تتسلى تنبسط تتعلم
تتثقف توصل بسرعه للمعلومه ولكن كمان ممكن
تكون سبب بادمان ممكن يصيبك ويصيب كل حدا
حواليك لذلك احنا لازم نضل عنا
لازم نضلنا قراب من بعض
نحط وقت من يومنا للثاني للقراءه
وبهيك بنكون احنا ساعدنا الاخرين ساعدنا
نفسنا
كنت انا معكم ساره خصاونه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]